i went to a local market that uh
that
has a parking lot such that there's
really only one way in and you have to
there's basically one parking space that
is the most prominent in the parking lot
and there was a big guy sitting in that
most prominent space
in a minivan with the driver's door
propped open and he kind of had one of
his legs hanging out at the door a
really big guy you know very masculine
seeming um seemed very strong kind of
time worn embattled and bittered
i don't know the guy
um i know that i
walked out of my way not to walk past
him
which is the natural way to get into
that market anyone who's ever been at
this market will will know that the way
you would normally go into the market
through that parking lot is right past
his open door where he had his
leg out and i noticed um both on my way
in on my way out it was a beautiful day
and there were a lot of people around
that i was not the only one that no one
was walking right right by him which
they normally would have done
and um
the thing is he wasn't just a big
potentially threatening dude
who was doing something kind of
display-like with his door open his leg
out
but he was also wearing fishnet
stockings
and i think a mini skirt
and garish makeup
on his face
and
that didn't make him a woman
but what it did do
i suspect was made a lot of people more
confused about their own responses
if that had just been a guy dressed like
a guy that guy dressed like that guy
doing that thing it would have been read
as what it was
which was
a subtle
threat
to really everyone but certainly women
and because he was dressed in sort of
feminine tropes
nothing happened now would anything have
happened would it would would an
employee from the store have come out
and told him that he needed to close his
door and go somewhere else if he had
just been dressed as a guy i don't know
maybe not
but i think the chances that this would
happen with him just the way he was
are much much lower
and this is downstream of diversity
equity and inclusion stuff
because until yesterday everyone knew
what a woman was and that putting on a
skirt doesn't make you a woman
and as we've said over and over and over
again this does not deny actually truly
trans people
but this man
no
this man was doing something aggressive
and threatening in a public place in a
way that made it less likely that anyone
would call him out on it
um
all right
this only works at the rule of thumb
level
but all of the trans people that i have
known
well enough to really say that i know
them as people
to a person
have made every effort
to fit in to their chosen gender as
seamlessly as possible right
what you're describing is somebody who
has weaponized their
chosen gender and raises questions about
why they chose it in other words it's
the point that you get a weapon for
doing this is the point that you get to
be a burly guy who people steer clear of
but now you get to make them feel
uncomfortable about it because you know
is it transphobia that's causing them to
do that
so i guess the question is
every time i see somebody
for whom their presentation
is aggressive and which the point is not
to minimize
the
sense of
uh discourseness or just coarseness no
discordantness would be the word i was
looking for
you know anytime somebody is
um
aggressively
utilizing those tropes so that they are
in conflict with
how they present
such that they would know that that's
what they're doing it raises a question
about why they're doing it yeah
yes no that's exactly right
uh so just
one more
note about this um
i've been reading of late some uh
historical fiction about uh world war ii
and pre-world war ii era
i think i made i mentioned a number of
weeks back about uh um
a novel about hedy lamarr and i've also
been reading some fiction written during
the gilded age and
and
all of these books have strong female
characters what
when you say hedy lamarr
it is almost impossible not to quote
harpy corman say headley
in
blazing blazing yes yes
um
yeah not not that lamar the the real
well but he he he spent that whole movie
correcting people because of that exact
problem but exactly
um
so so books ranging from 1880s through
1940s
written either about that era or during
that era with strong female characters
which reveal of course that there have
been strong women who have been you know
fighting against the particular
strictures of the cultural expectations
of them because of the sex they were
born to
for you know for a long time
and
i was reminded with this
with running into this guy in this
parking lot
of
this flyer of a 1914 feminist rally that
a few years back barry weiss actually
posted and if you can show my screen
here this is from 1914
what is feminism come and find out first
feminist mass meeting
with the at the people's institute at
cooper union 1914
and
the topics
uh the subject is supposedly breaking
into the human race and the topics given
by a series of speakers are the right to
work
the right of the mother to her
profession
the right to her convictions the right
to her name the right to organize the
right to ignore fashion i love that one
and the right to specialize in home
industries i don't know what that last
one means
but all the rest of them i think are
extraordinary yeah um and i'm i could
probably figure it out i welcome someone
telling me what the right to specialize
in home industries means
because it seems like that is the thing
that women have always
been in fact you know canalized into
right now that does that
specialize within home industries yeah
yeah
anyway but the rest of them you know the
the right to round name to her
convictions to organize to ignore
fashion to work and um the right of the
mother to her profession not just to
work but to work even after you've
become a mother
these are this this is feminism in 1914
this is what women were fighting for and
in response to
barry back in early 2018's this is
several years old at this point
why is my computer not coming up
i said okay so in feminism 1914 we had
the right to work to have convictions to
keep one's name to organize and to
ignore fashion feminism in 2018 and this
holds today unfortunately
the right to ignore science to attain
power through victimhood and to make
arguments that nobody is allowed to
dispute
so this was sort of just as um let's see
early 2018 maybe this was before
actually me too really came no me too
what happened me too was this was me too
was full swing and me too was a movement
that we needed and it was not the
movement that we needed right like me
too
needed to say some things to the world
we needed a me too movement not the one
we got yeah exactly and so
in the in sort of the thick of that
there was a you know hashtag believe all
women moment as if women like all the
other human beings out there that say
the other 50
can't and wouldn't lie for you know
for personal profit under some
circumstances not all
but also um
not none right and so
that
you know
what feminism has become is terrible
it's tragic uh but it's also just become
even more ridiculous by the idea now
that well okay well if women get that
right
and you're a dude and you don't have
anything else to recommend to the
progressive stack well then all you have
to do is put on fishnets and now um you
got to believe me not only that i'm a
woman but anything else i want to claim
so you know this
that's what that's part of what and it's
not entirely on your doorstep dei guys
but the diversity equity and inclusion
community has brought us that
that's
nightmare which is effectively a hostile
and alienating space it's not just a
workspace it's an everything space
hostile and alienating to everyone who
is interested in
being good and doing good for each other
so i want to
definitely resonate with your point
about hostile work environment and
and larger environment but i also want
to point out
it's not just that uh
the ei creates a hostile work
environment
that is its mechanism of action that's
its mo yes all right it's modus operandi
yes and the point is that's how it gains
power is by creating an environment in
which you are unsafe and in which what
happens is
at the point that the mob focuses on you
you are now in danger not only of being
accused of terrible things but losing
your right to earn losing your ability
to advance right to the point is what
you want to avoid is the anger of the
mob which causes you to become their
tool or to be cast out yes and so
uh it reminds me a little bit
there was an i think it was the delilah
affair at the beginning of the george w
bush administration
there was this one democrat who had been
brought in
and i forgot what he did but something
in the white house
and
he wrote an article at some point he was
very alarmed
that
there was no policy arm of the
administration it was all pr going on in
the in the white house
yeah it was all spin
and there was there were no discussions
about what we should be doing as a
nation to solve x y and z problem all it
was was basically how do we accomplish
these goals that we walked through the
door with right
and it alarmed him in any way he wrote
about it and terrible things happened of
course because you're not allowed to say
those kinds of things but somewhere in
that affair i believe that's where this
comes from
um the point was
not only are these people abusing power
it's who they are
that's what this is this this
administration is about the abuse of
power i would say the same thing about
the biden administration incidentally um
but the fact is
creation a claiming that we have a
hostile work environment and we need to
render it on hostile as you are making
that environment hostile and really the
point is oh
you want to make it hostile and you want
to be immunized from anybody pointing
out that that's what you're doing
and so the whole point is what we're
trying to do is create an unhostile
environment no
quite the opposite preemptively claim
that your goals are the opposite of what
they are or the are the opposite of what
you are actually going to do perhaps
it's just collateral damage even if you
know maybe you just don't even care that
it's hostile now uh and i guess the one
the one final thing i would say here
before we move on is
we were getting there
right and this again is a point that
we've made a lot
but the 20th century saw tremendous
advances
women's rights civil rights gay rights
workers rights children's rights you
know all all of these demographics and
all of these
real
pressing human rights issues
that
really
the liberals won yeah we did it well we
weren't we did it we made the world
better we weren't there and in fact
there are a lot of conservatives out
there
vast majority of them who adopted those
values as part of their own and are now
the defenders of them because what we
have now is people who call themselves
on the left
destroying it you know undoing undoing
the game so many people now
would
never say yeah i'm a feminist or would
question whether or not we need
movements to
maintain uh the hard-won civil rights
that happened you know through have
happened throughout history but you know
came to a came to a four in the 1960s
and these are not these are not by and
large bad people or mean-spirited people
they're just fed up with the lies that
they're being told about
about what is actually happening so you
know stop undoing history stop
pretending that we haven't already
gotten a tremendous amount of the way
that we need to go
and
you know
if you're a scientist
consider doing science consider actually
when you're trying to figure out if
something is true like for instance uh
there are you know not not enough
however you define that uh black faculty
among the sciences sciences among
scientists um
what are your possible explanations for
why and you need to come up with all of
them you can't come up with one and
stick with that one and claim that
you're doing science because you're not
yep absolutely
we need we need science back in science
[Music]